foreign
good afternoon everybody it's uh two
o'clock and welcome to the meeting of
the auditing governance committee
um can I just remind members when they
speak to turn their microphones on and
off when they finish speaking
so we can capture it for the broadcast
um
item one on the agenda apologies for
absence so Sandra yes chair one apology
councilor Locke
thank you very much
minutes of the previous meeting held on
the 17th of January Pages three to eight
I'll do a very quick page Turner
Pages three
four
five
foreign
six seven and finally eight
so if nobody has any comment on those
I'm going to move from the chair that we
confirm those has been a true record so
all those in favor if I have a seconder
Doug I caught your eye first
um
well those in favor
and that is unanimous
item three Declarations of Interest
members with interest should refer to
the agenda item and describe the nature
of their interest when the item is
considered
item four agreement of agenda items part
one and two we do have a part two item
today we've had two part two items today
so I'm going to move from the chair that
at the appropriate time we go into part
two if I have a seconder for that please
okay Sinclair thank you all those in
favor
again unanimous
so we'll go on to item five
urgent matters brought forward with the
permission of the chair I don't have any
items and none have come before me so we
will go on to item number six
the draft DAP in turn Road it plan for
tourist District Council
2023-24 Pages 9 to 19 and to receive a
report from Devon audit partnership
manager so Paul the floor is yours
yes good afternoon Paul middle Mass from
Devon Hall departure this paper is our
draft audit planned for for this year
starting in in April 2023
um the plan we're proposing is for 177
days this is a slight increase from last
year's plan of about when it's eight
eight day increase
the document provides the sort of
indicative days against each of the
audit areas but
um just obviously highlighting those are
indicative and obviously we'll do less
or more audit days as we need to the
plan includes specific follow-ups of
areas such as housing options and
includes areas such as um our annual
sort of audit on cyber security
um it's intended to be a live plan so
we'll bring in work as we need to as
things arise
um and appendix a provides the list of
the the audits that we propose to do
this year so
um one reason to expose it towards the
committee is obviously you get your
agreement to it but also to get your
um thoughts on any audits that you want
us to to do this financial year
so I'll open it to the floor
right
any comments from the floor
yes Ruth
just just one comment um when I went to
the Devon audit partnership meeting
um it came out that we haven't got any
fraud cases but everybody else has so I
was wondering if you thought there was
any area that we need to specifically
look at where there might be likely
fraud that we're missing
um so
um
obviously Ken Johnson did a paper for
the last story committee where we
reviewed the sort of counter fraud
Arrangements you had in place I suppose
what what we think is perhaps missing in
there is for um and something that some
other council is doing is perhaps for
you to focus on your top half a dozen
um significant business areas where
fraud might be present and do a fraud
risk register for each of them
um so you can have a super active
approach to identifying the types of
fraud that the fraud that might be
occurring
um obviously if you
um so that that's I suppose the approach
that we're we're suggesting council's
take
because there's not enough emphasis on
being proactive in terms of looking
looking for it rather than
just falling over it so to speak
it seems online
share that our people are better behaved
than everybody else is so I would have
thought that if they
I mean I think it's maybe incorrect to
say there isn't any evidence of fraud in
turret I mean clearly on housing
benefits all the time we
uncover fraud
and in our processing of claims for
household support payments we have
curtailed a few applications where we've
had
suspicions that people may not be being
truthful with the council so that's not
people often
when they get single person discount for
council tax don't inform the council
once somebody moves into the profit sir
so it's not right to say we haven't got
a fraud I think probably what the more
was saying is we haven't been covered
Maybe
a fraud within say somebody submitting
false invoices to the council but it's
to say that there's no fraud in housing
benefits council tax discounts would be
around us
okay thank you
right the only comment I would make
um you know very clearly we are
if you wish an outgoing committee
and we're subject to
the election next month
should the incoming committee wish to
revisit this timetable for whatever
reason we're not hamstringing them today
by
the decisions we make at this meeting
I'm just sort of asking that
rhetorically
I know you're not and obviously I I
repeat it's alive it's a live plan and
happy to share with the next boarding
committee is an item for them to have a
look at and and comment
um
okay thank you
thank you um
are we looking to just
record this to note this or we're
looking just to confirm it basically
under those terms
for us to approve this
it's it's to review a note share
recommendation
okay so Julie noted
um we'll move on to item seven audit
reports issued to date Pages 20 to 24.
back to you again Paul please
yes so
um the report has summaries for free or
audits that we've completed
um but also notes on on page 20 that
we're um because completing quite a few
other significant bits of work including
on insurance and governance and payroll
and information governance
um also you may be aware I distributed a
recent report on cyber security in fact
it was just yesterday
um it's not um summarized in in the
report but I know that officers are sort
of due to talk about cyber security
later in this meeting so just just to
comment
um pleased to see that we provided a
reasonable this I suppose compares to
um
out but sort of three or four other
councils I also sort of support
um two had limited
um and and the two as have reasonable so
that's a good place I think for the
council to be in and I know the number
of recommendations were quite low
um
in terms of the um or audits where the
summary so obviously the summary on the
State Management so this was a follow-up
of a piece of work we did last year
obviously we welcome a new uh strategic
asset plan indeed have highlighted it to
other councils as as good practice and
we think it's a good start to putting in
into place a more proactive and
systematic approach to dealing with
assets and so on
um housing benefit council tax support
again
um we think there's good good
Arrangements in in place to manage that
area
um I think one of the diagram in on my
paper anyway seems to be missing
um so the the the actual diagram shows
that
um
there's been a state of reduction over
the last five years from about one
million pounds
um in outstanding debt to about 553
000 pounds so they're sustained
reduction in in the amount of housing
benefit debt
um and so we think overpayment's a well
managed and monitored and uh there's a
range of different approaches to
recover the payments
um that that includes having a specific
officer to concentrate on on on recovery
um and also finally we also undertook an
investigation into the disabled facility
Grant
um as it states in the summary for lack
of clarity on the discretion on the
discretion of officers in terms of what
they could they could approve
um leading to instances where they spend
you know exceeded the grant limits
um and also of your trial justifying the
decisions was also not not sufficient so
we made quite a few recommendations to
officers to um to resolve or to help
improve controls
so that's that's my update happy to take
any questions
people do we have any questions from the
committee
no right
um again
we're happy to note
those reports
yep okay
and we move on to item number eight the
external audit plan
Pages 25 to 53 to receive report report
from Grant Thornton so Andrew welcome to
the committee if you'd like to give us
an update or report please thank you
chair Andrew Davis from Grand Thornton
um it's okay chair I'll start with a
brief sort of verbal update as to where
we are on all the on the various various
deliverables before going on to the uh
the 22 23 external audit plan so
following the previous committee the
2020-21
opinion has been issued
as as the certificate closing that
particular audit year so that's that's
all that's all done and finished
uh 21 22 in terms of the financial
statements side of the work the work is
finished that hasn't been signed yet and
that there is likely to be now a further
delay to that and the reason for that is
yesterday the the triennial review of
the pension fund was completed and that
report was being issued so effectively
that the effective date of that report
is the 31st of March
2022 so therefore
all firms have to have regard to this
now because effectively what it what it
is is a post balance sheet event because
as at that date we had the balance sheet
figure that said there was a liability a
pension liability and a reserve that
matches that
now they've reviewed that we need to
then kind of get comfortable that that
number
hasn't changed or it will have changed
but then it's what we do about it
whether there's an extra disclose that
needs to go in the account so
effectively what's happened is
as a firm we've paused all 21 22
signings so no more will be signed until
we've been able to resolve this the The
Firm the so the leadership team is
speaking to the various actuaries
including Barn waddingham who are the
torridges actuary
um and and trying to get this resolved
as soon as possible they've taken a
sample of a uh a few of our clients to
look at and Trace through to see what
the impact of that is going to be yeah
it's going to be a material movement you
know there's definitely going to be a
material movement there and I suspect
um it'll require further disclosure in
the accounts before we can sign those
off so it it's frustrating
um but but that's that's where we are
with the 21-22 and hopefully it'll be
resolved as as quickly as possible and
then we can move sign the accounts off
um 21 22 vfm is still that that's in
progress and we're doing that in tandem
now as we've started off on the 22-23
value for money work
um and you know we'll come on into the
plan
obviously with with David retiring and
trying to kind of get as much of that
done before before David moves on so
that we can we can get as much of that
done before he has to get passed on to
somebody else so we're trying to trying
to work with the with the team too to
sort of mitigate that that risk a little
bit
um I think that that's all I wanted to
cover in terms of an update
um I mean I'm happy to take questions on
the the try on your review side of
things albeit
at the moment it it's all a bit of an
unknown this only came out yesterday so
um I'll obviously keep David updated as
to kind of what what's going on in in
terms of where we're going in terms of
these samples they're looking at to see
what the impact is but but I suspect you
know that there will be an additional
disclosure required
in terms of those potential changes to
the numbers in the account
if it's move on then to the to the audit
plan so the audit plan starts on page 25
and this sets out the risks for the
audit for
2022-23
there's been a few changes this year
um
you know we've got the usual risks in
there but there's there's additional
risks because we've got the group audit
for this year which is quite a it's
quite a significant change and then
obviously as I've already spoken about
we've obviously got uh David and friend
leaving which is a risk but almost a
it's a different kind of risk which I'll
which I'll come on to
so if it's okay I'll just go through the
plan and just talk through it a bit more
than I would do normally just because of
those
particular changes for this year
the key points to summarized on page on
page 30 and
and I'll I'll just talk to that page
first if that that's okay
the First Column talks about the
significant risks
now management override of control that
that's a given that's for all audits we
we have to do that we do all our work
around journals estimates and and
anywhere that he might be perceived that
management might manipulate the accounts
to get the fine the financial position
that they want
um so we do a significant amount of work
around that and that is required by the
Isis
now the next two we've got revenue
recognition and expenditure recognition
again these are presumed risks under the
Isis now normally for the council and
and that remains the case we would we
would rebut those risks and say actually
because of the control environment
because of the fact that a lot of the
income comes from Grants and you know
the the risk of fraud in those areas and
obviously we've talked about Ford
already in the meeting
is relatively low
so we remember we rebut those risks for
the council what we haven't done is
rebut those risks for for the revenue
side of things for
the subsidiary company so for active
storage
we've kept that in as a risk and that's
because you know we've got to get an
understanding of the revenue streams and
that's what we would do if we were
auditing a a private sector company
because there's an incentive
I'm not saying it's it's there but there
is an incentive to
inflate revenues because they want to
maximize shareholder wealth so we we're
less likely to rebut in that in that
circumstance where for the council you
know there's no there's no real
incentive there in terms of trying to
make things look better than they are
and then we've got the two the two usual
risks that we have in normal ones which
is the pension fund valuation and the uh
the valuation of property plant and
equipment
these are Big estimates they're big
numbers there's a lot of assumptions
that underpin those that are small
little movement in any one of those
assumptions can make a big difference
the numbers that are included in the
balance sheet so we do a significant
amount of work around those and that
that way that hasn't changed from from
in previous years and then the the other
risk that we've got in there this year
is group counts now it's it's a
relatively simple group and I don't
Envision to be in any problems because
well you know we've been talking with
David you know throughout the planning
around around this but it's the first
time that the council have produced
group accounts with that there's you
know there's a there's a consolidation
to be doing and canceling event into
group transactions and there's also a
raft of additional disclosures that are
required to kind of go along that to
make sure that they're all code
compliant so we've put it on there so
that we make sure that we give it you
know the attention that it deserves
especially in the first year and and
make sure we've got all those
disclosures correct so that going
forward it can then sort of roll on and
and build
the the materiality on there that's what
we work to so the the at the moment
because we haven't got Financial
statements for active torrage
the group materiality and the I'll call
it the single entity which is
effectively the council
um they're the same so we've got 700 000
is the materiality so anything if we
found any areas above that that would be
where we would you know potential impact
on our audit opinion and then the the
number at the bottom which is what the
the committee here
um
he's probably most interesting is a
triviality level which is 35
000 pounds so any error over 35 000
pounds that would be reported to this
committee
and that includes so we give our opinion
on the group
and the single entity so our opinion
covers both so that would all be
reported within our audience findings
report
value for money
we've got there's
um we're obviously we've still got our
workout standing for 2122 so we'll be
finishing up the work around the group
Arrangements
um and and finishing that off and then
linking that in with
um sort of a risk around Financial
sustainability and the general you know
the economic climate and and where
that's at you know and the challenges
that all councils are facing
um
so that was all I was going to cover on
there if I just quickly
I won't go through the rest of the risks
in detail but if I could just ask
members to turn to page
page 36
and that's where
we've got the
the group financial statements that's
the significant risk around the group
now
I'll I won't make the assumption that
anybody knows anything about group
counts so I'll just sort of just quickly
sort of have a just a Canter through
just so that you can kind of understand
almost what the process is and then when
you understand the process you can
understand
probably how our testing then aligns to
what we're doing so effectively what we
have is we'll have a normal set of
accounts and then you'll have a group
accounts which is effectively on a line
by line basis because active Torrid is a
is a it's a wholly owned subsidiary of
the council those items are effectively
added
to the councils
but any Intergroup transactions so where
for example tyridge Council pay active
storage and management fee
that is canceled out because otherwise
you'd be double counting those items of
income and expenditure so where they
where the where the group entities
Trend transact with each other
those get stripped out so now we
obviously we test that process to make
sure that it's been done correctly and
that those into group transactions are
adequately supported
and then we've obviously got all the
disclosures that that come with it which
is you know we we've which we'll go
through with um with David and that but
that's that's how the group accounts
works and that's how it will be
presented you'll see these two sets of
statements and then you'll have a where
there's a material difference between
two sets of accounts
you will have separate notes for those
particular items that are different
so that's what that's in terms of your
expectation of what to see and then we
will audit that to get to the position
where we can give the opinion on both
um so the capacity within a finance team
on page 37 isn't a significant risk
because we're not identifying it as a
risk of material misstatement it's just
the risk of delivery and the impact and
everything else excuse me but we've been
having conversations with with David on
this
um in terms of how we best mitigate the
risk now we've we've managed to get some
early resourcing for the end of June to
be able to start some of our detailed
testing so there's various areas that
David's responsible for I'll be looking
at those in June around sort of sort of
annual governance statement narrative
report things like that so doing that
early and then Carmen who's going to be
working on the audit we've agreed with
with Fran who's also leaving at the end
of July that's the kind of areas that
she's responsible for and we've
prioritized those and we'll be getting
the samples out early in those areas so
hopefully that's going to help mitigate
that risk so that just to be clear
that's not a risk of material
misstatement it'll be the same Finance
team producing the accounts and the
working papers it's just that you know
as much as we can get done that with
with those officers the better
the on page 38
we've got the group audit scope and risk
assessment and this is more on the group
and this just gives a little bit more
detail so
obviously active Tory doesn't come in as
expenditure and when we do consolidation
there will be amounts over and above
what were in the single entity account
now we have to get our Assurance on
those now the best way for us to do that
is as active storage of they've got in
order to to audit their accounts we will
seek to rely upon their work for that
and to do that I had a I had a meeting
with the partner from from westcott's
tail end of last week
um and you know we've we've talked about
the timelines reporting and and that all
seems to be lining up nicely
they're very much on board in terms of
so they'll be doing a lot of work around
income and expenditure testing
which we will then rely upon and to do
that
that involves us having to go to their
offices and we will review their work to
make sure that we are comfortable and
able to rely upon that but it's quite a
simple it's quite a simple group and
it's quite a a sort of a simple
consolidation
but we still have to go through all of
the processes to make sure we've got
that Assurance especially over the areas
that over and above after the
consolidation adjustments have been made
I wasn't really going to talk about
anything much more in the report
in the in the plan
um I mean I'm happy to take questions on
anything else it just it was more the
group I wanted to kind of focus on
because that is something that you
wouldn't have heard from us in the past
so I'm happy to take any questions here
do any members of the committee have any
questions Doug
um
more clearly
group order yeah I've not heard before
but this is kind of like since we've got
active colleges part of the equation
yeah that being the case
previously we haven't looked in
specifically to the accounts of previous
way that
that ledger operation as well and know
that it is part of our group to look at
that as I would be interested I think
know at the end of each try not to hear
exactly the additional culture
associated with looking at a sort of
really active towards side of the
accounts all these things are cut and
the reason I say that at the end of the
day we need to know exactly
part is Polish
they may come under when you say Western
event Thomas Westcott accountancy yes so
that's obviously another another deal
that has to be paid at the end of the
year so I think it's important for us
for us to know such this group but as a
counselor exactly what
the actor
sorry within active time you pay them a
management fee and that's been declared
and that will be reported within their
budget there is a budget for audit costs
for Thomas westacarp but there will be
you're right there will be additional
transfer and Grant Phantom to us for
undertaking the group accounts I don't
know if Andrew can share that at this
Junction it's in the um it's in the
audit plan on page 49 so there's there's
an additional five thousand pounds
charge for the
um for the additional procedures on on
the group yeah
five thousand times
David do you have any comments or
observations I know this is a very sort
of fast movie narrative with things
coming to light in the last few days
um
sorry in some ways what I think is the
positive I think within the finance team
and with our colleagues from Grandpa we
actually know what the problems are
ahead to face in that we've got a
strange arrays where an active Nation
are doing the basic account on behalf of
active Torrid but then we've got third
party Thomas question it's been a while
did that give us that but the group
accounts are really quite simple you
know I can tell you now the three
entries where we
um interact with each other we pay
active tolerance and management fee so
that's expenditure on our side it's
income on our on their side on
consolidation that disappears to zero
they pay a fee to our HR department for
HR Support so that's an expense on
active Torrid and income on the
council's department that'll disappear
and the last one is we charge them for
their office accommodation up at
cardstown so they've been expensing up
to Turret and income on the council's
part and they disappear on consolidation
in terms of any sort of like balance
sheet because we own the asset
at the Leisure centers so there's going
to be relatively small balances from
active Taurus they'll be credited some
invoices they haven't paid and it may be
some debtors it might be some swimming
clubs that haven't paid them at the end
of the year so they're going to have
very limited and cash in their Bank
they're probably the only balance sheet
items of any significance they'll have
so on consolidation the reconciliation
shouldn't be too difficult to be
truthful it's ensuring that our
colleagues in active Nation Paul the
correct accrual through and we'll have a
center check on that you know so they're
accounting for utility bills that they
haven't paid for example
but thank you
okay I think we've got a both um handle
on that and thank you for taking it
through the system so concisely and
relatively
um
at this stage we just note your report
and um thank you for the work you've
done Andrew thank you
we move on to item nine
order to Greed actions page 54 and over
to you David uh thank you chair
um as Paul mentioned earlier on
dap acting as our internal audit do
various reports throughout the year
and when they do the reports have their
findings a management respond to the
findings and say
what actions they will take in response
to the findings and the findings at our
colleagues at dap do have correct me for
wrongful four categories so they have a
high
you know the council needs to act
quickly on this medium
low and I think the fourth category is
opportunity I believe so what I've done
is I've gone through all the audit
reports that have been issued and
extracted those
um
management responses which are late and
that's what's summarized on that page is
there several in a part two item Stacy
you'll go through sort of housing
options separately
so all it is for information is to show
you what is late what management hasn't
adhered to the timetable that they said
um you know two in cemeteries of health
and safety there's an estate so there's
one in a risk management on the right
hand side is the category
which is medium
the second to right column is a Commons
for the late actions
um have to take any questions it's just
to report back to you where managers
haven't met the deadlines they
originally set themselves
right thank you dude I think this is all
very self-explanatory unless anybody
wants to make the comment we would just
duly note
okay so with Julie note item nine
and move on to item 10 non-compliance
with procedural rules and waivers Pages
55 to 62 over to you again baby thank
you chair so the council has done um
Financial procedures contract procedure
rules
and there's a very simple one I think
we've just recently changed the
financial procedurals in terms of the
levels at which we have to go off of
course but generally over a certain
amount of expenditure we need to go out
for quotes
free quote for some work so what the
report does it details
the instances where the council has not
abided by its own Financial procedures
so if you turn to page 56
you should be able to see a little chart
and
if you and it goes by year so it shows a
number of times that the council
didn't follow its Financial procedures
and what we'll do and we're not going to
follow we fill out what's called a
contract waiver form which has to be
signed up by myself and
um Stacy as monitoring officer
so as you can see in 2223 there were six
instances where we didn't follow the
financial procedures in terms of
contrast and these various reasons but
sometimes it's urgency you haven't got
the time to do it and it could be a
health and safety risk if we don't get
worked on urgently sometimes it's on
limited demand
and so what's also listed in the report
is the x-rats of the
um contract waivers saying what they
related to and the reasons why we didn't
follow the financial procedures I think
the main thing is you're always going to
expect
even in the best years and the best
intention the best forward plan there's
always going to be instances where we
have to act quickly for whatever reason
or there is only one supplier
um six
that would seem to me personally to be
an acceptable level the number of times
that we've done that you know if you
look back in over years about 20 that
probably said there was something more
systematically wrong in how the council
was
um undertaking its Affairs happy to take
any questions if there are any
quite happy with that figure person is
because I know full well that um over
the years trying to get
um different
contractors to actually quote for works
out you're planning on on you know
taking out is extremely difficult you
know some of them dragged their heels so
bad so much it's you know you've just
got to get on with that and sometimes
it's almost impossible to get three
quotes sometimes you're lucky if you can
get to
sorry for absolute Clarity if we go out
to solicit quotes and we only get one
quote that wouldn't generate a contract
waiver because we'd follow the procedure
just so we're absolutely clear on that
okay
yes Ruth thanks chair
um I just got a query on the rough
sleepers
um I understand it's very difficult with
the government not giving as consistent
amounts of money and they keep dropping
and changing the schemes and so on but
it seems to me unsatisfactory to go from
one year to the next not knowing who is
going to be dealing with it I mean my
preference would be for it to be
in-house so we always know where we are
but for the I'm particularly concerned
about well the workers were a start but
also the vulnerable people
because
if the contract can change from year to
year and we use a different charity or
different organization to carry out this
work it means You're vulnerable people
have just got used to one person and
started trusting them
and they can work with them and then
there's a danger that we might change
from one charity to another charity and
they've got to and also you know
everything has to change well not
everything has to change but it could
change within changing from diff one
group to another I I wonder why we can't
have their three-year contract rather
than just this one year to the next year
because our funding's only agreed year
by year but the reason that we've done
the waiver on this occasion is because
we are staying with the same charity who
who assist us
um that's that's Encompass it's very
limited
um organizations within this area that
that will help but this does stay within
torridge we get some funding
on top from Devon County and to assist
us in intervening in in rough sleeping
it would be towards's responsibility
anyway but currently and we have done
for many years worked alongside
encompass
all right imagine I just repeat what I
said why can't we have a three-year
contract that I understand that
Government funding is unreliable but I
just think if we have to carry out this
service we should be clear who's doing
it we should you know have
a proper procedure so that we know what
we're doing not be going from one year
to the next
because I find things only given from
one year to an ex so when you say
um a three-year contract
I'm not sure I'm clear so ask the
statutory of responsibility is torridges
we get funding occasionally to assist us
from Devon County Council on top they
only confirm that funding year on year
so we contract with Encompass year on
year and we can't do longer contracts
because of the funding we don't get told
three years in advance in relation to
the funding we get told and when the
budgets are set every year so if we gave
a longer contract we're tied into
paying the monies whether we get
assistance or not
just start as well if the contract
actually changed it'd probably be two P
Arrangements in place anyway so that
people would be dealing with the people
of vulnerable people we're dealing with
the same stuff because they were
probably two be over
so we're duly note that on item 10. and
move on to item 11 which is the forward
plan on page 63.
I'm just looking at the whole plan for
the 18th of July we probably should have
undergoing concern report on that that
agenda item probably should have been In
fairness on this agenda item
so if we could add a going concern
report to the 18th of July meeting
yeah okay
right okay we will Julie note that
and
I will go on to item 12 exclusion the
public
and I would like to move that the public
be excluded from the remainder of the
meeting because of the likely disclosure
of exempt information by virtue of
paragraph 3 part 1 and paragraph 10 of
part two of schedule 12a of the Local
Government Act 1972.
so I moved that from the chair and
looking for a second to clear thank you
all those in favor
and that is unanimous so if we go
and take down the live feed please